[MUSIC PLAYING]
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: The things
I will be talking about
probably are not very
usual to hear from me now.
Because usually I have
meetings with people
and talk about civil
society, about culture,
about political
things in my country--
But I decided when I
was asked to talk here,
to choose something
different and to talk
about history, science,
technology, everything
together.
I started this sort
of presentation--
I started thinking about that--
during my semester at Yale
University two years ago.
One year and a half ago.
So at one of the
seminars I proposed
the idea of 20 inventions
that changed the world.
And it was somehow popular.
We had a big
argument after that.
So I thought it out afterwards.
I added some stuff.
So now I'll try to talk about
these 20 inventions that
changed the world--
and as they say, that
pushed boundaries--
It's not only innovations.
It's just some of
them are innovations.
Some of them are discoveries.
Some of them are just
inventions by chance, you know.
Or as [? Dima ?]
says, by accident.
Some good things are happening
by accident, somehow.
And some of them are probably
will be argued by your audience
and can be--
let's find a
compromise at the end.
So I'm very, very happy
that you are here.
I know that this is a
very intelligent audience.
And I will be very short.
Probably 20 to 25 minutes.
Or 30 minutes maximum.
And then probably you'll
ask me some questions
on what you've heard.
And then probably you
can ask me some questions
about everything.
I'm very, very much free
to answer everything.
And I'll be all ears.
So we'll start from
these 20 inventions.
One thing, it's a shame that
I don't have a PowerPoint
presentation, but you know
I really didn't have time
to try to make it.
Also I'm not very
strong in PowerPoint.
Always my PA, Anya does it
for me and we were on tour.
So all I have is a very,
very old school stuff.
And if you want to learn by
heart the things that I'll
tell you, or just put down
some things in your notebooks--
so it will be great.
So when we talk about
these inventions
and about innovations
that changed or created
what a human being
is now, I think
one should think out of the box.
So we're not going to talk about
just technological breakdowns,
or breakthroughs, or
technological revolutions.
Or just some devices.
Because many of us
when we talk about--
today, when we hear
about inventions,
we're thinking about laptops,
or computers, or smartphones,
or all electrical cattles--
name it.
But things are more interesting
and everything starts
from the very beginning--
In my point of view, probably
the biggest invention
that was made by a
human being, even
before we started to name
ourselves Homo sapiens,
was the invention of hot food.
Hot food is something
unique, because we
are the only animals in the
world that consume hot food.
And as you probably know, hot
food is much easier to digest.
And when we started
actually eating--
I think it was
also by accident--
eating meat that was baked,
literally, in some charcoal--
or just, I don't
know how it happened.
But we started doing it,
and once we got more energy
to save, and that energy
went to transform to sugar,
and that sugar
went to our brain.
And our brain started to
grow, and it increased.
And actually, hot food--
most scientists argue-- was
much more responsible for making
our brains bigger than
even that the fact
that we walk on two legs,
which is also very important.
But that's something
that we didn't create.
But this innovation
to eat hot food,
I think it started the
whole process of creating
of a human being today.
And from that it
allowed us to proceed.
The second, very serious
innovation, or invention,
is language.
A language-- not only language
like communication, but what
human beings, Homo sapiens,
were able to derive
from this language.
As you probably know, before
Homo sapiens ruled the world,
there were other Homos
who inhabited our world.
These were like
Neanderthals, Homo habilis,
or even there was Homo denisova.
It was a special
species of homos
who were living in Siberia.
All of them don't exist anymore.
Human beings, Homo sapiens
conquered everything,
rule the world.
Unfortunately, they
exterminated 80%
of all living
creatures in the world,
even before scientific and
industrial revolutions.
We did it, 20,000,
30,000 years ago.
So language, which human
beings, or Homo sapiens used,
differed from language as a
homos, or even animals used.
Animals can communicate.
For example, they can
say that there is danger.
There is water there.
So some primitive things.
Neanderthals, they
also used hot food,
so their brains also
were bigger than animals.
And some say that even bigger
than Homo sapiens' brains.
But their language was still
this kind of primitive,
and very straightforward.
What Homo sapiens created
was an abstract thinking,
and language that used notions
and ideas that actually do not
exist.
So that was our strength.
So we used language
to describe things
that actually don't exist.
There is one very,
very interesting book--
you can read it.
It says, I think, Homo
sapiens and something,
I don't remember.
At the end I will
give you a name
because I just don't remember.
They have a good fact there.
That Neanderthals could
communicate in a way
that, there is a lion and
this lion is dangerous,
we should be aware
of it, and that's it.
Dangerous lion, we fight him,
or we escape, or we hide.
But what Homo sapiens
made, they went further.
They created things like, lion
can be a symbol of our forest.
Or lion, he's a
defender of our forest--
which actually, from the point
of matter of fact, is bullshit.
I mean, a lion cannot
be anybody but lion.
But human beings,
somehow, created
this kind of abstract thinking.
And their language
allowed them to imagine
things that don't exist.
That consequently led
to myths and religion.
And that actually made
possible to gather
large groups of people.
Much more than hundreds
of people, but even
thousands of people together.
You cannot stick together just
because you live in some area.
Because people lived
in small tribes--
100, 200 people.
But when you share the common
beliefs, or the common things--
like for example, that a lion
is a master of the forest--
it makes your bodies in the
other forest understandable.
And you can communicate, and
then that makes strong bonds.
And actually, this made
Homo sapiens so powerful.
They could create tribes--
not of hundreds of people,
but thousands of people.
And that's how they literally
exterminated all their rivals.
So that will be the second
fundamental invention, which is
language and abstract thinking.
The third is the
only one I didn't
include in my previous list.
But in the argument
that we had afterwards,
it came up to my
head that probably it
was a very important one and I
should include into the list--
its money.
Because money actually
created interaction
between all human beings.
Continuous interaction.
It's also a sort of myth
or a sort of religion.
Because money is actually
an abstract thing.
It doesn't exist
as we understand,
because it's not
a material thing.
But it created something
that all people believed in.
And actually, probably,
it's the only religion
that all seven or eight billion
people believe in today.
And that's something that can--
Look at that.
You can argue about whether
Christianity or Islam,
or some other
religions, are better.
Or some people don't
believe in God.
But nobody argues about money.
I mean, it's very
hard to find somebody
except Shaolin monks, who
just don't use money--
Money changed everything.
Money changed
behavior of people.
And they made them more--
When we say materialistic,
it's not only bad thing,
it's something that
you become cautious.
Money makes people cautious.
And probably it
also preserved us
from doing or making
some big mistakes
at the beginning of our history.
Also money are,
unfortunately, pushing
us to make big, big
mistakes, huge mistakes,
now in this part of our history.
But anyway money
is number three.
Number four is writing.
And writing is
obvious invention,
but many things
existed before writing.
For example, oral
narratives allowed people
to have, once again, religion.
To have myths, to have
tales-- fairy tales.
To have everything.
But what created writing, it
created very important things
like law and science.
Because law is something
that should be--
you cannot treat it very
free, in a very free way.
You should know it, for
sure, how to use this law.
And narrative is very
rarely strict and precise.
Narrative can be--
I can say what
law is, you will say this to
somebody else, the same thing
but with distortion.
And finally, somebody
not in this room,
but in the other
room, will completely
hear the different thing.
So writing allows us
to see the same things.
And when we create
a judiciary system,
we talk about law, it's a
must to know exactly the same
that other people
know about these laws.
Suddenly signs and history
also started to develop.
Because you also save
a lot of your memory,
not for remembering all the
things that all your ancestors
created, but just doing all
your mundane and routine stuff
knowing that you can find
somewhere in a library
or whatever.
Suddenly the beginning
of creation of writing,
there were only a few
people in the world--
a few small percentage
of the world--
who had access to this to
this cave with precious gems,
or whatever.
How we call knowledge.
But generally, it started
changing the world as well.
And the fifth, in
my opinion is--
We already talked
about religion.
We could say that
religion is an invention.
But religion wasn't a true
invention because religion--
It took us thousands of years--
more and more and more--
to come from just
primitive beliefs,
to myths, to fairy tales, and
then to religion as we know it.
But there was one concrete,
and one specific invention,
where we talk about
religion, which
really changed the history
and the path of development
of human being.
Which is monotheism.
Because monotheism,
which was created,
some argue, in Egypt, the end
of their ruling 1,200 years
before Christ.
Some say that it was
created by Jewish people
when they create a Judaism.
We don't actually need
to understand exactly.
What we need to understand, that
for the first time in history
abstract thinking--
sort of that high--
that people created the idea of
invisible and transcendent god,
who is omnipotent.
And who also is very--
God cannot do bad things.
That's a big, big
difference from religion
that we had before.
For example, if you
talk about Greek gods.
Greek gods were very
much like people.
They behaved like people.
They cheated.
They killed.
They did all the sins
that we people do.
And actually, in ancient
pre-monotheism culture
it was still bad to kill
people, or to do some bad stuff.
But it was bad just
mostly because when
you kill people, when
you kill somebody,
you would be killed as well.
Or you would be punished
because you deprived some family
of labor force, or whatever.
But monotheism, and Judaism,
and Christianity, and Islam,
created moral.
So when we started believing
that to kill, or to steal,
or to cheat, is not bad just
because you violate some law,
but it's bad because it's bad.
And it is something that makes
your psyche suffer, and makes
your soul suffering,
and you feel bad.
And actually, this is
very obvious thing now.
So what about that?
We can think that moral
existed for all other time,
but it's not.
But it doesn't.
It didn't.
It exists only for
2,000 or 3,000 years.
Before that, moral
was different,
if it existed at all.
So what we now have, we behave
not only in a practical way,
and not only in an
instinctive way.
Instinctive way as
a way of animals.
Practical way is
something the human
being created, even
before monotheism emerged.
But what we call spiritual way--
or way of the conscious--
is something that this idea
that was probably first--
or one of the first times
described in ten commandments,
which we know from the Bible--
is a fundamental thing.
It also gave people
a freedom of choice.
So it described a human
being as a creature
which was granted by God
with freedom of choice.
And freedom of choice, either
to violate commandments or not.
To do this, or to do that.
So we are free to
do whatever we want,
but we know that at the end
we'll pay the price for that.
Or we'll be rewarded for that.
It changed human beings
behavior, I think, for good.
Because now we're
different people
than we were 2,000 or
3,000 thousand years ago.
So these five
inventions, I think
they are the most important.
Because they framed
what we are now.
And they framed our development
for the next 1,000 years.
The inventions I will be talking
later, they are more practical,
but they wouldn't be
possible without these five.
Fire gun weapon--
it's much later.
I put it as an invention,
as a separate invention.
I'm not talking
about cold weapon.
Because cold weapon--
even animals, even ape
used stones for fighting.
And it took us thousands of
years to come to good swords.
And to have all these weapons
of destruction that Greeks,
and Romans, and Chinese used.
But what fire gun weapon did,
it equalized possibilities
and military power
of rivals, or enemies
of people who fight each other.
Of states who fight each other.
And, as you know,
fire gun weapon--
although was it was
created in China--
but mostly developed
at the beginning
of the end of Middle
Ages and beginning
of Renaissance in Europe.
And finally it came to the point
when wars became unbearable.
So at the beginning a big
country a lot of military force
could conquer, easily,
a smaller country.
And just because they
came with horses and were
swords, and it was very
difficult to fight them.
But then, with fire
guns, and with mortars,
and with all these cannons, it's
much easier to defend yourself.
And the last war that showed
us the probably impossibility
of a former order, was a
Thirty Years' War in Europe,
that finally ended up with
Westphalia Peace, which
created modern states.
Because modern states is
something that we understand
as granted, although some
people question this now even
in 2000's.
We know about that.
But modern state, a
state with borders,
which is respected
by other states, no
matter how small or how weak
it is, once it's recognized,
it's recognized.
Before Thirty Years' War,
there was no notion like that.
Empires could do
whatever they wanted.
Big kingdoms, they
conquered smaller kingdoms
and acquired them
and did everything.
But now after Westphalia
Peace in 1648,
people started treating
states differently.
And the main reason for
that was that to fight wars
became very, very difficult,
and costful, and just--
Two million people died
during these three decades,
and nobody won.
Nobody.
It was still status quo.
So they just came
to the point where
they say we need to start
from the very beginning.
So if not the fire gun,
we wouldn't have had that.
Afterwards, some
scientific stuff.
Printing led to Protestantism,
as a consequence
to scientific and
industrial evolution
in northern countries.
Because printing made
knowledge affordable,
both in figurative
and direct meaning.
We started reading
books massively.
We started reading books in our
languages, they got printed.
And it was much easier to
read books than before.
You didn't need to know Latin.
And you didn't need to go to the
church to ask for permission.
If you had enough money,
you could buy these books.
And in 200 years after
printing was invented,
northern Europe was already
booming and developing
technologies and science.
Then discovery of
America by Europeans
also changed the
framework, and also changed
what the world is now.
You know that probably Chinese
could have discovered America.
They actually started
creating expeditions
during 15th century, but
they abruptly stopped them.
Nobody knows why.
Their ships were much bigger.
Their potency was much
stronger magnitude.
Their [INAUDIBLE] was way
better than these first Columbus
ships, they were really small.
But somehow Europeans
managed to do that.
And finally, it
led to the creation
of big European empires.
Who afterwards, through
missionaries, and also trade
companies, first enforced
the whole world to accept--
and then probably also promoted
with much milder means--
European way of
thinking, mindset.
And actually added it to life.
And nowadays we still have the
societies who think different.
But mostly European,
or I would say,
northern European practical
way of treating life,
is dominating in the world now.
And who knows if Chinese
discovered America what
the world would have been now.
We don't know.
We just know that
it was Europeans.
It was Columbus.
And finally, it's an interesting
irony, and very important
historical irony.
You probably know
that Columbus--
it was possible to organize
this expedition because Columbus
came to Spanish kings,
Ferdinand and Isabella in 1492.
It was the third time
he asked them for money.
Two times before they refused.
And 1492, they say OK,
we'll give you money.
We have money now.
Who knows why.
Some of you know
why it was 1492.
Why they couldn't do
that 1483, or something?
That was exactly the year
that Spanish kings finally
reconquered the last part of
Iberian Peninsula from Arabs.
And that year they
took Grenadian
where well a lot of Arabic
and Jewish rich people,
and they got all this money.
And they ruined all the stuff.
And these were money
that they started
using in their next endeavors.
And actually, Arab
and Jewish money
created a new Christian power.
And it's ironic, but that's
how sometimes history
is being done.
Then some scientific inventions.
Newton created his famous
laws, and Newton's mechanics,
and it changed the
attitude to facts.
Before Newton's
laws mostly people
believed that faith,
matter of faith,
was much more important
than matter of fact.
And Newton's laws
were the first time
when we could predict exactly,
without any divine force,
that if the ball is at point A
now that it will be in a point
B. And we knew 100% exactly.
And it made people belief
in fact very powerful.
And when we started
believing in facts,
we started thinking in
this more practical way.
And that how science
and industry developed.
And that's why England,
and other northern European
countries, started
proceeding and developing
so fast afterwards.
Facts, and matter of
facts, became dominating.
In other parts of the world,
especially for example,
in the part of the
world where most of us
are from, Eastern Europe,
or for example, Asia--
people didn't believe in
facts long afterwards.
So it took us probably 200
or 300 years afterwards.
Because societies like ours were
mainly transcendent and driven
by irrational things like faith.
And some spiritual things.
English people became very
practical-- and in a good way,
cynical--
much earlier.
And they started
to do achievements
in practical fields,
mostly because of science.
And Newton was the first, who
was the first person who opened
this door of matter of fact.
The direct consequence
of that, but I
think it's a single and
a separate invention,
was a steam machine of wood.
Because steam machine of
wood created modern industry.
Manifold time increased
labor power used by man.
And productivity, also.
And reduced cost
of productivity.
And liberated a
great amount of labor
force to do the
other job, like then
to be peasants in the fields.
So it created plants,
factories and everything.
Actually, the second
invention which
also was a consequence of
this scientific revolution,
was electricity.
And James Maxwell, a
Scottish scientist,
a very modest guy, who
was thinking, creating,
working on electricity.
Theoretically, he
created his Maxwell laws,
which allowed us to create
many things that we see now.
I don't think that LED's--
but probably just our electric
lights, or everything--
what electricity created.
And funny thing is, when
these laws were discovered
and written first in
scientific papers,
most scientists didn't
accept them well.
So it took probably 20 or 30
years before Maxwell theory
proved its practical
value and made
all of us using electricity.
Three medical inventions
happened during these times.
First was very important--
and it happened even
before or, probably
approximately the same time,
when Newton created his laws--
and it was invention,
or creation, or the idea
of blood circulation.
It was made by English
scientist Harvey,
and he first
understood that blood
is circulating from arteries
to capillaries, and then
through veins, back.
And actually, you may ask
why is it so important?
It is so important because
it gave us the idea what
really blood is for our body.
And it also gave
us the possibility
to heal and cure some diseases,
and some really bad things
with our bodies that
we couldn't do before.
For example, we understood
that gangrene is,
and all blood inflammations,
they cause deaths.
And they knew how to treat
it afterwards much easier.
But two inventions,
medical inventions,
that came later in the
beginning of the 20th century,
they even changed our life
even more rapid, and more
significant way.
These are vaccines
and antibiotics.
The first killed viruses,
the second killed bacterias.
And if vaccines helped us
to stop epidemics of plague,
and of Spanish flu--
all this kind of stuff--
and it helped in
a peaceful life,
then antibiotics helped
in healing and curing
wounded people, who were
wounded and injured during wars.
And in first World War,
which Americans, or Irish,
or British, called
Great War, people just
died because of
inflammation all the time.
Because they got everything.
They got pneumonia, they
got serious injuries,
nobody could get cure it.
But after antibiotics and
vaccines were invented,
the life expectancy
raised twice.
So at the beginning of the 20th
century it was 40 years, now
it's 75, or 70,
average in the world.
It's almost twice.
And I think these two
interventions probably
made a major contribution
to this fact.
If we talk about later
20th century inventions,
it's long distance connections.
Telegraph, telephone, and radio.
It's actually one invention.
We don't need to say
that it's three of them.
It created mass culture.
It created possibility to--
it made world flatter,
even before internet.
It didn't make world flat,
but it made it flatter.
And it was the first step in
the whole bunch of inventions
that were coming later.
But many things, like
radio, created pop music.
Radio created our first
political debates.
Radio created, like an
old telephone connect.
Connected all people
and relatives.
And it changed--
how to say this?
I mean, they changed
the way that we
treated each other,
friends and families.
For example, if you
have your phone,
you don't need to see
your parents every day,
or every week, you
just call them.
And then that
somehow alienates us.
And that's not a good thing.
But that's something
that telephone,
and other long distance
connection created.
We started changing
our everyday behavior.
Quantum mechanics, which
actually, probably some of you
know.
Quantum mechanics was created by
a very young scientist of age,
from 20 to 25, at the
turn of the 20th century.
And quantum mechanics makes
the job of all of you possible.
If not that, I
think there will be
no computers, no internet, no
Google, no this room, nothing.
Because that's where
everything started.
Three or four young scientists
in Germany, England,
and Austria, were so dare to say
that all the science they knew
before was completely bullshit,
and it didn't describe
the world of atoms, molecules,
and electrons, and particles.
So they created this new
science, which actually,
also, is a very important
cornerstone of civilization
of human beings.
Because it needs changing
of our perception.
It changed our perception
of what is matter of fact.
Because quantum mechanics is
actually something we cannot
understand by our brain.
If some of you, many
of you understand
what I'm talking about.
Some of you probably don't.
I'll explain.
Quantum mechanics says that
particle-- let's say electron--
can, if you see a big, big
house with 10 entrances--
So electron enter all these
entrances simultaneously.
Not being divided into
parts, being as a whole,
and you can find it in
each of these entrances,
at the same time,
and we'll be there.
So we cannot understand that.
I mean, our brain
is not quantum.
It is classical.
So we cannot understand.
How can it be possible that
one particle can be present
at the same moment of time, not
being divided in 10 entrances,
and it can enter
these entrances,
and there's still one particle.
But the truth is that
that's how the world works.
So it requires from us not
to understand, but to believe
in power effects.
To believe in experiments more
than an our analytical skills.
And it's something that
changed the science at all.
Because before that
what we did was--
we first made experiment, then
we started to understand that,
and then we started--
OK.
If our understanding corresponds
with our experiment, OK.
That's a good explanation.
But quantum mechanics, for the
first time, when we believe in
experiment even if we don't
understand how it works.
And that's a very
important thing.
Because the fact, and the power
of fact rules now our brains.
Before that, our brains
ruled everything.
That's why we saw that
the world was flat
and we couldn't believe
that our globe was round.
And we couldn't believe
that we our Earth
was rotating around sun.
We thought it was vice versa.
Because that was our brain.
Or our analytical
skills told us.
But quantum mechanics
changed it completely.
And suddenly, after
quantum mechanics
a couple of inventions that
we see now became possible.
Television.
Television, actually-- the
biggest impact television
had was, in my opinion,
it was not a pop culture.
But it was politics.
Because politics
created new politicians.
Created much bigger populism.
And when we now
regret about the times
when we had a big
political leaders,
and now we have just mediocre
politicians, one of the things
is television.
Because television gave
politicians possibility
not to talk person to
person, but then just to make
one appearance.
To say some primitive things
but to be very energetic.
And to be very persuasive.
And people started
believing in that.
And that's how--
Populism was
present in the world
before, way long
before television.
But television made
it an absolution.
And then, atomic energy, it's
the third revolution in energy
after steam and electricity.
I don't need to say about
good and bad impacts of that.
Chernobyl and Hiroshima
are one of the bad impacts,
but there are some also
good because it gives us
a great amount of energy.
And the last three
inventions, 18, 19, and 20, I
will not explain it
to you because you
will explain much more.
You know better about
these three inventions.
It's computer, it's internet,
and it's social networks.
The one thing I can say,
that I separate all of them
because I don't think
that they are free.
They are dependent, but
they are still separate.
Because computer
is something that
makes us powerful in counting.
In finding solutions.
Internet is something
that changes our--
it's something like writing.
When writing was created,
the information we had before
became useless and we
started using information
in a different way.
Internet-- it's the
other revolution.
I know that now all of you
are thinking about today's
knowledge and education.
And we understand
that after internet
the whole bunch of education
that we had before is useless.
What Google made now
makes 70% of what
is taught in schools
absolutely not necessary.
We need to change everything.
And countries like
Canada, like Ireland I
know, Finland, South
Korea, Israel--
already has changed a lot
of education of children.
We in Ukraine, for
example, in Eastern Europe,
still need to come closer.
And there was one
questionable invention
that I don't include
in the top 20
because I think that this
invention, or innovation, still
hasn't changed mankind.
But I do believe that it will.
And it's probably the
question, what's next?
In my point of view, it's what
I would call it neuroscience
and artificial intelligence.
We still don't know
how these two fields
will impact human beings.
We already see some things,
but it's only the beginning.
I really think that it will
be a fundamental change.
Both artificial intelligence
and the way of our
altering and
changing our brains.
It will create some unbelievable
stuff we cannot imagine.
I just believe it will come very
soon, probably in one or two
generations.
I think most of you
will witness it,
and then we'll see
how serious was it.
And will it be something that
comparable to hot food or not?
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thank you
very much, Slava.
Actually, I'm really happy
that I heard your lecture today
because you as a
creative person,
and a person who sees
things differently,
give me a little bit of
interesting perspective
about many things today.
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: Thank you.
SPEAKER: And we are
mostly engineers here,
so you know we are very
focused on engineering things
and this was much
wider than actually
I, personally, expected.
So I'm very happy to be here.
We still have, probably,
two minutes for questions.
And--
SLAVA VAKARCHUK:
Only two minutes?
SPEAKER: Well, four
but we still need to--
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: It's the end?
SPEAKER: No problem.
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: You should
have stopped me earlier.
SPEAKER: But I was
so happy about what
you were talking about that
I didn't want to stop you.
Don't worry about
this, it's fine--
SLAVA VAKARCHUK:
Can we have can we
have 10, 15 minutes, because
I'm struggling to get
some questions.
I came here to hear
people as well.
SPEAKER: Actually, we
need to ask our engineer
and see if they will
allow us to do it.
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: Yeah?
Thank you very much.
SPEAKER: Excellent.
SLAVA VAKARCHUK:
Appreciate it, mate.
SPEAKER: So we have
more time for questions.
Excellent.
So guys if you have any
questions from audience,
I will do it like this--
SLAVA VAKARCHUK:
From what we heard,
or something
completely different.
Don't hesitate.
SPEAKER: Don't worry.
Just don't please be
political, it's very important.
But everything else is fine.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Slava, thank you.
It's great to see you.
And--
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'll be
quick with my question.
If you think of--
first of all, people know
you through music, right?
So let's call you a
rock star, in a sense.
But--
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: In a sense.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: As
stereotypical, a rock star
would be doing a lot of
music, and let's say, drugs.
Whereas you, for example,
do a lot of music--
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: I
did beer yesterday.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: But you
do a lot of music,
and science and social,
and all of this.
So my question is, where do you
get the energy and inspiration?
How do you manage to
maintain this inspiration
to keep doing all of that?
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: It
depends on who you ask.
People who believe in
quantum mechanics or people
who believe in God.
I don't know.
Actually, I believe
in God and I think
these two correspond very well.
And I think that our
energy comes from God.
And God is not in
a religion way,
but it's something
big in the world
that you can concentrate
on, and you have
this channel of interaction.
And I know that I
sometimes have this energy
and I don't know
where it comes from.
Especially when you have
five concerts and a row
and at the end of
the five concert
you're still jumping and
singing, energetically.
I don't know.
It's not my credit.
It's somebody there.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So I see one person.
[INAUDIBLE]
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: Whoa!
SPEAKER: --games.
But we'll-- Sorry.
Thought
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: It looks nice.
SPEAKER: It's actually
a very good thing.
I like it.
AUDIENCE: Hello, Slava.
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much
for coming to us, and--
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: It's a great
honor to have you here.
My question would be
about your travel.
About your world tours.
You meet a lot of
Ukrainians who live abroad,
and what would be kind
of three main differences
with those people
who live in country?
Like if you meet
Diaspora Ukrainians,
what would be their
difference in the way
they would be thinking and--
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: You mean
comparable to Ukraine?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, comparing to
those people who live in the--
SLAVA VAKARCHUK:
Comparing to Ukraine.
You know, I will say only one.
And that makes, I think,
something optimistic.
You know, in our country
we always complain on how
Ukrainians are not effective,
they cannot create a proper
institution, they are not people
who can stick into some laws.
Sometimes not very hardworking--
That's something we
complaining about in comparison
to other countries.
But when I see Ukrainian
in other countries,
I see them among most
industrious, hardworking,
successful, and some of the most
successful people in the world.
That brings me to
the idea that that's
institutions and environment
that matters most.
And Ukrainians are people who,
in the world, make difference.
So the one thing we
need to do in Ukraine
to create these institutions
and that environment
that you have in
these countries.
So that's what we need to do.
And there is no
other difference.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE] Yeah.
Yeah.
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: That's
really ridiculous.
AUDIENCE: Hi Slava.
You've briefly touched on
the subject of education
and how it needs to change.
And I know your dad
was very passionate
about education
system and change,
as I was the witness of it.
So my question is,
how would you like
to see the education
system develop and progress
into 21st century?
And what changes would
you like to see first?
Thank you.
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: In my opinion,
the most important today
is not to give information to
children, which you are already
here in Google are doing.
So, probably you can have
one or two rivalries,
which I think is always good
for competition and for quality.
You still don't have.
But that's something we
need to leave behind.
What we need to do is to teach
children how to live lives.
How to live.
That is, how to
be a personality.
How to analyze.
How to percept.
How to perceive.
How to get, and how to give.
These things, that many thousand
years were abandoned, now,
little by little, are
starting to come closer.
And in some education systems,
they already dominate.
In the best universities
in the world,
that's what they
teach students now.
But in some countries,
we still in this--
I wouldn't say in Ice
Age, or Stone Age--
but it's still a lot
of things to be done.
So, I believe we
need to come to shift
our focus from information
to a personality.
SPEAKER: Who else?
Ahh.
You can throw it.
It's throwable.
It's like a game.
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: Throw it.
It's fine.
SPEAKER: Throw it.
Throw it.
Don't worry about this.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Slava.
Just a quick question--
that you mentioned
that the invention
of money made us
a bit more cautious,
for instance.
Several of the
things you mentioned
are about creating narratives,
and new narratives.
And how we should
believe stuff that we
haven't believed before.
Considering that,
especially in the West,
you're getting more
and more constrained
by economic circumstances by the
time you get to the age of 20
and 30, how do you see that
tension between material safety
and the need to challenge
the status quo, playing out
for our generation afterwards?
Would people have enough
freedom to actually create
a new narrative without fearing
for their material well-being?
SLAVA VAKARCHUK:
That's a good question,
and what we are
facing now is actually
the struggle between our
fears and our desires.
And because we see it
in Western Europe--
probably Western Europe
and Northern America
are pioneers in this
new environment--
we're going to live
some period of time.
I don't have an
answer about what
will be the end, or
consequence, or impact of that.
I don't have it.
I just know that, somehow,
people during the last 30,000
years of their history
were managed to create
a proper way to handle it.
Sometimes this is not
probably the best way.
You could find better.
But it's still as a
river, or a small creek,
it somehow finds its path.
And I believe that European--
and generally, not only
European but human being's
civilization--
will find its path.
That the side effect
of civilization
is that it makes
us more anxious.
And makes us more stressed.
And if the biggest problem
of our ancestors in Stone Age
was a fear to get
eaten by a lion.
If the biggest fear of
our Middle Aged colleagues
was to get sick and
die from plague,
so now our biggest fear is
our stress and our anxiety.
And more and more people
go crazy about that--
sometimes, literally, but
mostly figuratively-- and it
changes our everyday life.
And we become less
and less happy.
We need to understand that
to be happy you don't need
to have a big mansion in
London, or private jet, or even
a good computer.
Or even a great job,
or get good salary--
or even your family.
What makes you
happy is yourself.
It's your perception in
your brain, in your soul.
There are some people who
are happy to have 10 children
and be happy
fathers and mothers.
There are people who
are happy to travel
to the end of their lives
and not have families.
There are people who
want to have money
and they are really
happy to have money.
There are people who don't care.
But our nowaday narrative
gives less freedom.
All of us are forced
to live the same lives.
Here is one.
You need to have a good salary.
You to have wife and children,
or husband and children.
You need to be treated
correctly by society,
and you need to behave this way.
You cannot live in the forest.
You cannot do that.
But people who lived
300, 400 years ago,
1,000 years ago, sometimes
they suffered more.
But were they less happy?
Or are we more happy?
I don't think so.
There are some people who
have serious diseases who are
happier than healthy people.
So happiness, I think, is
much more important for us
than development.
So we need to
focus on happiness.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Last two.
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: Well, no, no.
Last three [INAUDIBLE]
because it's always like that.
Last three questions.
One, two, and there was three.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: Hi.
AUDIENCE: It's
actually a pleasure
to see you here, being a
fan of yours since I was 11.
I have a quick question.
So, because you're
a rock star, you're
kind of traveling
around the world
and see loads of countries.
The first question is,
what's your favorite country?
And second, would you ever
consider to move abroad
and leave--
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: To Ireland.
[LAUGHTER]
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: This is
not a political question.
SPEAKER: No, it's not
a political question.
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: I cannot say
which country is my favorite
country because I've been
to so many countries,
many of them has
things that I love.
I would say my last
love is Australia.
Because we went to Australia
this year and I think
Melbourne was a city that
most of our team and crew
fell in love with immediately.
The only bad thing--
probably also a good thing--
is it's very far.
And I think the bad things
makes good things, good.
Because I think
that was the country
when I met more happy people
than in any other place
in the world.
Australia, is my--
let's say, it's
present number one in my chart.
But you know, chart
always changes.
So probably Ireland
will be one day.
But I will say, exactly,
that from the point of view
of pub life, Ireland
is so far number one.
What we've seen yesterday--
me and Vlada, and Julia--
we haven't seen
anywhere in the world.
We poked in three
bars just to see.
And in each of them, we saw
like crazy parties singing
and doing-- you know,
I can't imagine it,
not only in Ukraine, but I can't
imagine it America, in the UK--
You can see it only
in Ireland, I think.
It's unbelievable.
How people are partying.
AUDIENCE: Maybe you
should stay a bit longer.
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Maybe you should
stay a bit longer and--
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: If my
favorite thing was partying,
then I probably will do
that, but no, it's not.
So-- two and three.
SPEAKER: Just throw it.
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: Poo!
Do want practice in basketball?
I used to play basketball,
I can teach you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I should have played more.
Thanks, Slava, for the talk.
I've been to a concert a
long time ago in [INAUDIBLE]
and so I have a question.
I have two questions.
You can either answer both,
or choose one of them.
First question, what are the
plans for your band, Okean
Elzy, and second one,
what's your opinion now
about Ukrainian music?
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: Our
plans for Okean Elzy,
I didn't intend to talk about
that in the nearest month,
so we wanted to make a
proper press conference
and to say something.
But I will throw
some light into that.
After we finish with this
tour, which is the end of June,
we'll make a break and we
don't know when will be next.
We don't have any
specific plans,
so we really don't
know when will
be next concerts, next
tours, next album.
We want to recuperate and
to relax, and just to think.
And I wish we come back as soon
as possible, but I don't know.
It can be a year, it can
be two, it can be five.
Nobody knows.
So that's something where
the question is open.
Ukrainian music.
Ukrainian music is unbelievable.
It is booming now.
I think that probably it's
one of the best periods
of Ukrainian music I've seen.
So many great bands
and musicians.
Some of them are
still underground.
Some of them are known already.
But it's great.
I'm looking forward to
seeing the next generation
of Ukrainian musicians becoming
as popular as Okean Elzy,
or even bigger.
SPEAKER: And the last question.
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: Yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER: Yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER: Excellent.
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: Good shot.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Slava.
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I want to finish on
the question that is actually
more related to innovations,
and you kind of talked
about artificial intelligence
and how important it's
going to be in the future.
Obviously, it's going to help
us solve simple problems.
But what about music and arts?
Do you think it will
overtake the human?
Or what's the value of
artificially created music
and art going to be?
SLAVA VAKARCHUK: I
don't know, exactly.
I don't know because you
come to a very important
philosophic question.
Is art a brain creation?
Or is art a--
what we call, a soul creation?
As a materialist, we
understand that soul
is a rather abstract thing.
Although some people can
say that you can derive it
from our neural system, from
serotonin, and [INAUDIBLE],
and all these things.
But I don't know.
From what I've seen
from first attempts
to do artificial music, it
sounds clumsy and awkward.
But it's only the beginning.
So probably one day
we will start crying
and we got goosebumps from
music that robots created.
I don't know.
You want my fair answer?
What do I want to see?
I'm a human being nationalist.
So I prefer that human beings
create human stuff and robot
create everything else.
But I'm not sure that
we'll be like that.
I don't know.
SPEAKER: OK.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]